ein guter tropfen aus dem holzfass kann
richtig teuer werden
günstiger geht s mit holzchips im
stahltank
[Musik]
was für ein intensives aroma
in windeseile entsteht eine
geschmacksexplosion aus lakritz
übernehme und zitrus eben noch im
tetrapack später schicken flasche mit
korken und etikett können unsere
experten da noch einen unterschied
erschmecken er hat gab stoff aber im
holz ausgebaut das weiß ich nicht aber
er hat gerbstoff im auftrag der
weinkönigin hat er die lizenz zum
tricksen sebastian liege
[Musik]
bis zu zwei jahre liegt ein guter
riecher im traditionellen 225 liter
holzfass dem barrique chemische
reaktionen zwischen wein und holz soll
in dieser zeit für die entstehung eines
komplexen aroma feuerwerks der
holzfässer jedoch rar und teuer sind
lagern die meisten weine für den
schnellen verkauf in riesigen stahltanks
geschmack gibt ja kein ab auf das
berühmte barrick aroma muss man aber
keinesfalls verzichten wie die
industrieumsätze bastian dafür auf eine
scharfe klinge und frisches eichenholz
die ausbeute schöne eichenholz chips
hochwertigen wein macht man ja in
eichenfässern in masse viel zu
kostspielig
mit reinen holzchips gehen wir uns aber
nicht zufrieden
für ein intensiveres aroma flambiert
sebastian die holzchips was für ein
intensives aroma ich das super hat ein
bisschen was von lagerfeuer camping
romantik ehrlich herr sebastian nicht
abschweifen was passiert denn jetzt eine
kleine brise reicht schon um richtig
viel wein ein vernünftiges holz aroma zu
geben
für immer sagen eben noch im tetrapack
später schicken flasche mit korken und
etikett
seit 2009 ist das verfahren in der eu
zugelassen
die schnipsel bieten dem wein eine
größere angriffsfläche als das holzfass
nur noch zwei wochen muss der trick wein
so lagern
übrigens winzer müssen gibson bei nicht
kennzeichnen aber steht auf der flasche
im eichenfass gelagert oder barrique
gereift muss dieser auch in fast von
innen gesehen haben
ich bin ja mal gespannt ob das später
einer aus schmeckt wenn wir jetzt hier
den wein mindestens eine woche stehen
lassen mit denen holz ships die leute
uns auf die schliche kommen und sagen
lecker schönes buch im eichenfass
ausgelagert
er lagerte schön und pappe und wurde von
rundholz schirms versetzt
[Musik]
ob sebastian strikt wein auffliegt
wollen wir an der aa in rheinland-pfalz
herausfinden
die region ist bekannt für ihre
aromatischen rotweinen nehmen sebastians
eigenkreationen für zwei euro treten ein
professioneller chips der australier für
fünf euro oder ein echter barrique für
16 euro an
eine jury aus sommeliers weinhändlern
und hobby winzern stellt ihre feinen
gaumen zur verfügung
hallo ihr lieben
schön dass ihr alle gekommen seid dann
haben wir ja die geballte weinkompetenz
jan dem tisch und da bin ich ja mal
gespannt ob ihr das alles raus schmeckt
was wir euch gleich kredenzen feind
dekantiert stehen die weine bereit
wir beginnen mit dem echten barrique
wein holzfass oder chips die jury ist
direkt auf dem richtigen weg ja das
wollte ich schon sei es schon mal
richtig eifrig genauer auf jeden fall
werde wird sich helfrich ok schön
ich denke es könnte fast sein jahres
wasserwerks mir gefällt der wein ja
merkel wird sich im fass gelagert der
teure barrique trifft auf gegenliebe
ob sebastians billig-version er
mithalten kann
[Musik]
ich probiere jetzt mal aber okay der
wird aber schnell ausgespuckt ganz
anders der kork hat
ein fehler
er riecht wer riecht sie naturtrüber
apfelsaft naturtrüber apfelsaft der
richten nicht nach war ich so ein
bisschen mehr nach much too much ton ich
dachte der riecht nach spanien
meine ich extrem guter tropfen nein
also ja es waren wir noch nie getrunken
nein nein er kann niemals im holzfass
gewesen sein da lege ich meine hand für
uns vor das ist ein stahltank weil die
kenner sind sebastian streak wein auf
die schliche gekommen aber fällt damit
auch die chips methode durch wir
schicken den australischen wein aus dem
supermarkt ins rennen auch der wurde mit
eichen spielen versetzt das ist sehr
schön
also diese wein hat tatsächlich als
erster ein bisschen den termin also die
die gerbstoffe merkt man auf der zunge
auch der könnte auch ein paar hang
stehen was meinst du bei dem im holz
ausgebaut
er hat stoff er hat gerbstoff abermals
ausgebaut das weiß ich nicht aber er hat
gerbstoff
der chips wein aus dem supermarkt kommt
überraschend gut an
während der lagerung sind offenbar
genügen gerbstoffe vom holz in den
bayern übergegangen gechipt bedeutet
also nicht gleich schlecht
[Musik]
im gegensatz zu sebastian setzt die
industrie aber auf ein deutlich
komplizierteres verfahren für jede
weinsorte unterscheidet sich die ideale
größe und rüstung der holzchips zur
erinnerung ob der wein geschubst wurde
sehen wir auf der flasche nicht und auch
die aufschrift barrique oder im
eichenfass gelagert verspricht nicht
immer top qualität bei weinen unter zehn
euro werden nicht selten alte fässer
verwendet die kaum nachgeschmack abgeben
ein günstiger chips dabei kann da
durchaus vollmundiger seien nicht in
fässern gereift aber dafür genauso
lecker lagern auf unserem kanal tricks
checks und duelle aus der welt der
lebensmittel